Indian foreign minister subramanyam
jaishankar is in Moscow and meeting
ministers including his counterpart
Sergey lavrov the two countries have a
complicated relationship Delhi has
indicated that it will try to push
Moscow for an end to the war in Ukraine
saying it's no good for the world but
since Russia's Invasion and Europe's
pivot away from Russian oil India has
been the one to pick up the slack and
Russia is now the country's largest
supplier of oil despite criticism India
has doubled down on its choice
it is our fundamental obligation to
ensure that the Indian consumer has the
best possible access on the most
advantageous terms to International
markets and in that respect uh quite
honestly we have seen that the India
Russia relationship has worked to
Advantage so if it works to my advantage
I would like to keep it in that keep
that going
India has also pointed out that Europe
continues to take more Russian crude oil
than India even now
Delhi choosing to maintain good
relations with Moscow underscores the
two countries long history together
India walks the line as a non-aligned
state notably it did not stand with the
group of democracies at the United
Nations when it came to condemning the
invasion of Ukraine here's DW's Chief
International editor Richard Walker to
explain more the UN Security Council
February 2022 the high table of world
affairs gathers to pass judgment on
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
her India's Ambassador is here holding
his country's non-permanent seat
he calls for a ceasefire we urge that
all efforts are made for the immediate
secession of violence and hostilities
the Western Powers vote to condemn the
war Russia casts its veto and India
abstains
what was India doing here it was joining
the likes of China in refusing to
condemn Russia's Invasion well this
wasn't a matter of principle this was
all about pragmatism
and not wanting to anger a valued friend
Delhi just two months earlier Vladimir
Putin on a rare trip abroad heaping
Praise on his hosts
the relationship has roots in the depths
of the Cold War
in 1971 Indra Gandhi and Leonid Brezhnev
were both concerned about tensions with
China
the result the indo-soviet Treaty of
Peace friendship and cooperation
India's policy of non-alignment meant
the treaty stopped short of being a full
Alliance but it helped to seal moscow's
position as India's number one arm
supplier something that's not been
forgotten
J panda is Vice President of India's
governing BJP party Russia or the former
Soviet Union had stood by India when we
needed defense capabilities to deal with
these challenges of China and others it
was the Soviet Union and continuing into
Russia that gave us equipment
fast forward to the end of 2021 and
Putin's visit to Delhi and arms were
very much on the agenda
Russia is supplying high-tech gear like
its s 400 air defense missiles to India
that deal is so sensitive that the
United States has threatened India with
sanctions for it but Delhi is sticking
to the deal Encounters of the West won't
match Russia on providing the military
Tech that it needs we are still denied
certain key defense Technologies which
are critical for our safety and for our
security and we have been getting them
from Russia Moscow has also done deals
allowing Indian manufacturers to make
Hardware like these Russian tanks that's
something other suppliers have been
reluctant to do
India not only gets the tanks it also
boosts its own defense industry a major
strategic priority
India's years-long Reliance on Russian
military hardware however isn't looking
so good almost nine months since the war
started in Ukraine Russian weapons have
not performed well on the battlefield
and that plus Russia's closer ties with
India's Regional rival China may explain
prime minister Narendra modi's recent
comments to Putin at an in-person Summit
to his face Modi said quote I know that
today's era is not an era of war and I
have spoken to you on the phone about
this and quote suggesting that the two
leaders had stronger words in private
to talk about all this we have harsh
Pond professor of international
relations with King's College London
thanks so much for joining the program
Professor can you parse what's happening
here because we see we've seen India
abstaining at the um but we've also seen
modi's recent tough comments to Putin
it's a quite a line to walk
yes indeed I think India has been
working a very very delicate balance
between its various Partnerships various
commitments and various kinds of
interests that are becoming Salient to
its foreign policy from defense to
energy to geopolitics and and I think
there is a growing discomfort in India
that the war that the conflict in
Ukraine has dragged on that there is no
site of a resolution yet and it is
having an impact you know globally in
economic terms and it is also certainly
having an impact on India's domestic
political economy itself so I think
India is now more vocal about the need
to bring it to an end talking directly
to Mr Putin as you mentioned but also on
the other hand trying to make the most
of the energy security as well as the
defense requirements for which it
continues to rely on Russia so it's
indeed a delicate balance
yeah definitely a geopolitical challenge
um I wonder if you can talk about how
China fits into all of this I mean India
and China have had border clashes in
recent years where soldiers on both
sides were killed but now we see Russia
and China cozing up where does that put
Delhi
in a very very difficult position and I
think uh that's why we are we are there
is a lot of concern in India about the
the the state of geopolitics at the
moment because uh you know as you were
mentioning India and China are at a very
very difficult position at this point
even as we speak soldiers are almost
eyeball to eyeball along the border
there has been some disengagement from
2020 uh when the when the escalation
happened when violence happened when
soldiers died but the de-escalation has
not really resulted uh in anything
substantive the the ties are very very
delicately poised at the moment and uh
the fact that Russia which is which has
been traditionally India's partner over
the last several decades especially
during the Cold War and now seems to be
becoming a close Ally of of China at a
time where India relies on Russia for
its defense supplies is very very I
think an extraordinary situation to be
end and therefore India perhaps is one
of the unique countries in the world at
the moment that needs Russia to manage
China at the at the border operationally
tactically as well as U.S and the West
to manage China more strategically at
the global level over the long term so I
think it's a very very difficult
position to be in diplomatically
yeah the foreign Ministry must be pretty
busy now India is also of course part of
the Quad that includes the U.S Australia
and Japan so how does it manage that
group of democracies with its
relationship uh with Russia and China is
it possible to do all of that
at least they are I think at the moment
trying to do that and and
uh I think the challenge for India
remains that uh it is facing pressures
from two sides uh the Continental
pressure from Eurasia where China is
pressing its claims along the border
along the Himalayan border and of course
you have the vast Maritime space that we
now call as the indo-pacific where again
we are witnessing a lot of geopolitical
contestation and India is trying to
partner with like-minded countries in
the wider indo-pacific so as to create a
stable balance of power in that vast
emerging geography and in that context
its relationship with quad members
becomes important because it's not
simply the U.S but also close allies of
the U.S like Japan and Australia that
are that make the court along with India
and India is partnering with these
countries to ensure that there is some
kind of stability in the maritime space
harsh Pond thank you so much for joining
us